[Music]
if you have young children you know the
challenge of looking after them and
trying to work it's a constant
exhausting juggle for a lot of parents
child care is essential and it's just
not back to where it was pre-pandemic a
national survey conducted for the
Canadian child care Federation found
that 36 percent of child care centres
that closed because of kovat 19 might
not reopen at all and 38 percent of home
daycares could remain closed those that
are reopening face a precarious
financial future sixty-eight percent say
they're worse off than they were before
Mike Joel a looks at the rocky road to
recovery of child care every day in
cities and towns across the country kids
are dropped off to start their days it's
about socialization the economy and the
collective sanity of parents everywhere
oh she absolutely loves it Beatrice had
only been in daycare three months when
everything shut down for her mama
Julia Mackenzie it meant balancing the
work she had just returned to with the
needs of a toddler she now had to care
for 24 hours a day so maybe about three
weeks ago we both kind of said okay we
don't know how much longer we could do
this we need some help
do we need to hire a nanny what's what
are our options here there's a lot of
guilt and familiarity to parents in
those words with no familial support
because of kovat 19 Beatrice spent more
time in front of the TV than normal and
no time interacting with other kids
after three months she's become
distrustful of others and in the street
when people walk too close to her I
noticed she clings to me so that's been
a huge concern actually it scares me a
little bit I don't want her to become
you're full and I don't want her to
learn that it's not okay to to play with
people but in the new reality Beatrice
who returns to daycare on Monday is one
of the lucky ones because there are
fewer childcare spots available BC has
implemented strict rules when it comes
to contact and distancing with children
but has an assigned a number for how
large groups can be Manitoba recently
removed its size restrictions Quebec
will follow suit in July but Alberta
Saskatchewan Ontario New Brunswick and
Nova Scotia have imposed strict limits
to keep groups small which has
effectively shrunk the system's capacity
a Toronto city councilor estimates there
will be 56,000 fewer spots in Toronto
alone Amy O'Neill of treetop childcare
says her Center can't opened under the
current limit of 10 people per room
including teachers so we usually have
approximately 155 but we're licensed for
many more with the new reopening
guidelines I could accommodate 24
financially she says they'd be bankrupt
within two months and on a personal note
she wants nothing to do with the
lotteries other centers have used to
assign the spots they do have that's not
our business to decide who is eligible
and who is not O'Neill is waiting for
direction from the government until then
she and the families that rely on her
are in limbo in Peterborough the staff
of nearly a dozen daycares decided the
situation was untenable and recently
took to the streets to protest Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau did announce an
aid package this past week stating what
some critics say was pretty obvious well
child care is going to require more
spaces more rooms more space in
different modifications which will cost
more money so we want to be there to
help that child care advocates are
asking that 2.5 billion of the 14
billion dollars pledged be earmarked to
help address critical issues beyond that
Carolyn ferns of the Ontario Coalition
for better childcare says the guidelines
as a whole are far too restrictive and
Ontario children can be picked up by
their teachers
provided a blanket is between them and
that blanket can't be used again I know
that from early childhood educators that
I have spoken with that's one of their
top concerns they don't want to be
running a childcare program with
children in chalk squares and even more
perplexing is this nugget from the
provinces 20 pages of guidelines
children should not do activities that
involve sharing toys and they should
avoid singing that's just not a
realistic expectation considering the
push for small groups home daycares
would seem to be a logical alternative
over a half of we watch as thousand
homes continue to operate during the
pandemic and they have a list of new
daycares ready to go but the first aid
courses they need for certification are
still closed
we could have 120 spaces available
pretty quickly but we can't get the
certification and we've asked if they
could do small group sizes like
one-on-ones or maybe three providers in
a room a little social distance then we
can do the whole thing how do we work
around this and we just can't seem to
get anywhere it's more red tape more
rules more uncertainty for an essential
service I don't know they keep saying
it's based on medicine and evidence and
I wonder if it's more political putting
excessive guidelines around children
isn't practical
argues dr. Anna Banerjee because they're
considered low-risk to a virus that is
unlikely to be completely eradicated I
don't think we can contain it I think
slow it down but I think until we have a
vaccine or until there's a current
immunity Co it's gonna be around for a
while these next few months will be
critical for child care providers to
prove they can handle outbreaks and
provide a reprieve for parents it's
having a huge impact on people as well
you can only hold back the floodgates
for so long